early copies of pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl seem to have
leaked back for blood has revealed its
road map for its upcoming dlc and more
i'm persia and this is your gamespot
news
early copies of pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl are out in the
wild and certain social media accounts
are currently posting all kinds of new
footage and details related to the
upcoming remakes ahead of their official
november 19th release date as reported
by vgc leaks started popping up over the
weekend when a reddit user posted to the
pokeleaks subreddit claiming to have
received a physical copy of the nintendo
switch game early previously unreleased
gameplay footage has since appeared on
youtube and various twitter accounts
have tweeted out all kinds of new
details from the games including in-game
music screenshots of the game's map
previously unseen models battle gameplay
and even more fans are scouring over the
leaks to see what previously unannounced
content can be found if you don't want
to be spoiled in regards to what kind of
surprises pokemon brilliant diamond and
shining pearl may have in store it might
be best to steer clear of any pokemon
centric circles on social media or
youtube nintendo looks to be taking
action against some of the leaks as some
leaked gameplay footage is no longer
available on youtube the user who posted
on poke leaks has since deleted their
initial post as well possibly to avoid
illegal action from nintendo and the
pokemon company it's not the first time
a major pokemon title has leaked early
though pokemon sword and shield also
leaked in 2019. that leak saw nintendo
taking legal action against those
responsible to the tune of a
150 thousand dollar settlement
bandai namco has released detailed specs
on its pc playstation and xbox versions
of the long-awaited alden ring on pc the
game offers 4k resolution with hdr and
retracing with the frame rate capped at
60fps
on consoles the performance will vary
based on your playstation or xbox model
but both ps5 and xbox series x support
4k 60fps in performance mode and hdr ray
tracing will be added to both via a
patch the ps4 version can be ported to
ps5 and your saved data will transfer
but it's a one-way street you can't go
back to ps4 or switch between them xbox
platforms will have cross generation
capability letting you play across both
however last gen consoles are only going
to get up to 30 fps for the title we
recently got a much lengthier look at
elden ring and you can check that out
along with the full spec details on
gamespot.com
back for blood the newly released pc and
console shooter from the developers of
left 4 dead is getting a good amount of
post launch dlc and this studio has now
run through what's coming the post
launch content roadmap includes free
updates and releases that are part of a
paid four annual pass the free updates
include a solo offline mode which
players had been requesting since launch
as well as a new difficulty level
another co-op mode new cards and a new
card type and seasonal content for the
holidays as for the paid content the
tunnels of terror expansion is coming in
2022 it features a new story another
activity type and more weapons cards and
skins more details about tunnels of
terror will be announced later it's the
first of three expansions included in
the annual pass which costs forty
dollars or is available through the back
for blood deluxe and ultimate editions
back for blood was released in early
october and quickly picked up more than
6 million players the game no doubt
enjoyed a surge in players thanks in
part to it being included with game pass
so if you do have game pass and you
haven't given it a shot it looks like
now is a great time to catch up
the xbox is coming up on its 20th
anniversary and to celebrate the
occasion microsoft is holding a video
broadcast the company has now shared
more details about the event in terms of
how to watch and what to expect
the xbox anniversary celebration as it's
officially called airs on monday
november 15th which is 20 years to the
day after the original xbox and halo
combat evolved released in 2001. the
broadcast will air on the official xbox
channels on youtube twitch and facebook
and you'll be able to watch the event
right here on gamespot as well subtitles
will be available in many different
languages along with american sign
language and audio descriptions in
english on the xbox youtube channel
in terms of what the broadcast will
bring microsoft said it will serve as a
celebration of some of our favorite
moments from the past 20 years of xbox
there will not be any game announcements
but as for specifics about what will be
there well microsoft has not said yet
microsoft is also hosting an xbox fan
fest event on saturday november 13th at
2pm pacific and 5pm eastern where it
will host an xbox related trivia contest
you can sign up on the fan fest website
but the cutoff is coming up quickly
you'll have until midnight on november
9th to sign up as part of this event
microsoft will announce the first
details on some 20th anniversary
giveaways
additionally microsoft will add more
xbox items to the xbox gear store on
november 15th that aim to celebrate all
things xbox though microsoft did not say
what they might be there's also another
change coming soon xbox live gold and
game pass ultimate membership badges
which are displayed on xbox profile
pages are getting updated for the 20th
anniversary microsoft stated the old
badges which showcase how long you've
been a member of xbox game pass ultimate
or xbox live gold will be replaced with
a colorful new badge these badges will
start to arrive beginning next week
after the event
all right mass effect fans i know n7 day
was over the weekend but did you see the
new mass effect teaser the striking
artwork shows a massive crater on an
alien world and it seemingly contains a
series of clues about its plot and
characters what do you want to see in
the next mass effect let me know in the
comments below and be sure to leave a
like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next gamespot news update thank you
so much for watching and we'll catch you
guys next time
[Music]
you